So your suggestion was to take a modeler and use it to take turn transitions
into a model, but once we have a model, you already told us last time
how we can use a planner to spit out a policy. You didn't talk about
those planners. What are, what's the name
of the algorithms that you described last time?
>> Value iteration and policy iteration.
>> Yes, right. So, so what you can do is, is run either
of those algorithms in here. They both have the same API right, they both
take models and spit out policies.
>> True.
>> Alright, so, so let's do this as a quiz. We'll say, let's use your idea of
mapping transitions to model to policy. And what
would you call this whole box? Right? And so
as a whole box, it takes transitions in
and, and produces policy out. So it is solving
the reinforcement learning problem. But it's taking a
very particular approach to it. But let's contrast it
with the, with kind of the opposite idea. Which is,
we can also map a model through a simulator into
transitions. And then if we have the ability to do
reinforcement learning. We can use, turn those transitions into a policy.
So again, as a, as a, composed system. This is
turning a model into a policy, so it is a kind
of planner, but it's a planner that uses a learner
inside and this is a learner that uses a planner inside.
So just, as, just out of curiosity I would like to,
just ask people what they'd want to call these. I'm not going to grade
these, but I just I'm just interested. Like, what would you call
this approach? Does that make sense? Just type it in the box.
>> Let's pretend it makes sense.
>> Alright. Go.